>> I do believe India can become a superpower
in the coming years to
come, or the decades to come, but what India
needs to strengthen from
inside is its infrastructure, its energy security,
dependence on
various forms of energy needs to be increased.
Primarily with focus on renewables like solar,
wind, and various other
forms of energy.
Education is another thing that needs to be
strengthened to create a
workforce for the world which adds quality
and value for all the
services around the world.
Manufacturing is another area that India needs
to focus on, and it's
already doing, getting the highways in place
to move the Indian
economic goods in and out of the country,
within the country, making
the hinterlands, reaching out to the hinterlands
with power, telecom
and various other progressive materials is
what makes India a
superpower in the future.
And I think we're geared up for that and we
should be going for that.